首先的话呢就是说什么叫m game对吧
m game的话呢其实叫massive multiplayer online gaming
他其实讲的意思就是说我们有很多很多的玩家
然后呢他们在这个多人在一个世界里面去online的连接在一起
这种游戏其实很多了
大家会想到m是不是都是指的在我们比如说在中国
我们讲mo很多人都觉得是m o r p g对吧
但实际上并不是的
比如现在的无论是这个f p s游戏
其实很多都已经是m了
就是用户量非常大
那么mo这就是说当玩家online联系在一起啊
这些游戏其实啊很早就已经有了
其实最早的一个这是我们课程组找到的最早的这个networking
连在联网在一起的游戏对吧
大家一起几个人一起走个迷宫
互相去经济
那么其实呢最早的这个multiplayer这个role playing game的话
其实是文字游戏
哎这个游戏这种叫什么
就是那个叫这个是最早的
但是我记得我们很早以前玩过一种游戏叫做mut啊
那真是充满乐趣的一个时代啊
大家在那边就是说我进了一个房间
我在桌上捡起了一个碗
然后门的那个房间的左边有个门
房间的那个有个桌子
桌子前面坐了谁
你是上去跟他讲话
还是决定出门推门而出对吧
哎真的是玩的大学时代
那个时候真的玩的不亦乐乎对吧
ok所以说其实呢这就是online游戏
它这个最早的雏形
其实online游戏真的是个非常了不起的一种游戏类型
就是猫猫这种游戏就是说它真的让用户能够连接在一起
我们第一次能够在一个cyberal word里面能够感知到彼此
所以随着这么多年的发展的话
其实现代的m o的话已经变得非常的丰富和完善了
就是说今天我们去进入到一个m游戏的时候
我个人的感觉啊
那其实就是一个小的虚拟世界
我个人还是蛮认可鸡胖讲的那句话
就是说现在很多人讲什么元宇宙什么的
他就说你们这些讲元宇宙的人
你们还不如打打游戏呢对吧
如果你打打这个我们mo游戏的话
比如说你打个final fantasy对吧
你就知道了
那个那你们你讲的很多东西人家就已经有了呀
对不对
在那里面就是在梦的世界里面
我们就可以进行星空探索对吧
我们也可以进行这个一起去挖矿
一起去做什么各种很有趣的事情
所以说实际上的话呢
就是现代的m游戏的话已经变得极为复杂和丰富了
那么其实呢他和一个单独的做一个gameplay
比如刚才在前面我们教大家更多的是说诶
我们一个session就是一个战斗里面
我们怎么去玩呢
就大家怎么去战斗
但是我真的去构建一个这样的一个网上的这样的一个虚拟世界
能够让几10万上百万的人能在这个世界里面彼此连接
一起进一起下战场对吧
一起在这个主城里互相能看见
而且在这里面的话
我们还可以互相对话
互相交易
这样的一个游戏世界该怎么去架呢
哎今天这个section的话呢
我就给大家简单的讲一下这个结构
其实呢如果要解决这个问题
其实你会发现一下子多了很多的子系统
比如说我们就需要对很多的玩家数据进行管理
我们需要user management的这个系统
我们的这些玩家在一起
我们要去匹配对战或者一起下副本对吧
我们需要一个matchmaking系统
对不对
然后呢我们还有什么呢
我们彼此之间还有能交易对吧
我们有的交易甚至是会牵扯到大家真实世界的货币
那就是非常严肃了
对不对
就大家知道在网游里面的话
如果你的道具被偷了的话
这个有的时候严重的时候是会直接产生法律责任的
为什么
因为它实际上是有经济属性的
所以说他的确定系统可能也要做得非常的严格
要保护好玩家们的安全
另外一个的话呢
我在这个世界你们还跟别人交好友啊
我要跟他去聊天啊
对不对
我还可以组织更重要的这个社群啊
这种公告啊
所以说诶我还需要一个社交系统
那最后呢我这么多的数据存在
那我们还有一个data系统存在
这大家会发现没有
就是说从一个单纯的只是构建一个小小的那个游戏的一个场景
我们在彼此去玩
去打一个session的时候
真正你做一款mmo的时候
实际上这个系统就会变得非常的复杂
它有很多的subsistence构成
那这个系统会以什么样的结构在一起呢
这边的话呢是我们画的一个非常简单的一个m的architecture
那么在这最上面的话呢是各种各样的玩家对吧
玩家连接到我们这个世界里面
那首先的话呢有一层叫link层
就是连接层
连接层干什么呢
就是说哎这么多用户他要login到我们的世界里面
他还有个login server对吧
它还有一个叫gateway
待会我给他解释
就这一层就是我们把用户的所有的链接管理好
然后接下来有很多的服务了
这些服务层的话呢
它就会提供各种各样的服务
比如说账号那个就是你的房间那个大厅服务啊
你的每一局对战的服务啊对吧
你的社交服务啊
你的这个存储服务啊等等等等等的这些服务
然后最下面一层是什么呢
有真正的数据存储层
有各种各样的db
就数据库那个那个数
以数据库为核心构建的这样的一个数据存储和服务层
所以你可以看一个就是一个网游的架构啊
大概就是三层
这三层是最核心的
那么首先的话呢从一个最简单的就是呃也不叫巨匠
其实挺复杂的
就是这个这个连接这一层来讲
有两个概念
可能是大家没有做过网游的人没有概念
第一个就是我们要做一个login server
就是我们那么复杂的这个就是这个游戏的m的服务器
它本身是一个一定要被保护起来的一个这样的一个东西
所以呢所有的用户不是直接往服务器里面去连的
他都是要先跟我们一个叫login server训练在那里面干嘛呢
诶我们要完成链接
我们要完成握手
大家还记得我们前面讲htb对吧
其实在真实的时候
我们一般会用http s吧
我们要经过更安全的信道的去加密
我们连到一起
我们要验证你的什么账号密码
这样我才能允许你登录我的游戏
好
我允许玩家你登录的
你假设用的真实的账号密码的时候
我是不是就允许你直接开始跟我的各个server去token呢
诶不好意思
绝对不行
这个时候你要做一个叫晚关服务服务器的服务
这个叫gateway
为什么要做这个gateway呢
其实大家一般会讲很多关于gateway的功能对吧
gateway有很多功能
我待会会讲
但是gateway在你从最至少是我个人的一个理解
它最核心的作用是什么呢
也就是说用户他永远只跟gateway去talk
而gateway才会负责和内部的
比如说character server
角色服务器啊
lobby服务器啊
就是大厅服务器啊
什么邮件服务器去t
大家想想看怎么去理解它
其实非常简单
对不对
它就是一个防火墙
也就是说因为虽然你有正确的账号和密码
假假设你这个黑客
你是不是会给我发很多很奇怪的数据
尝试去这个破解我的服务器的很多东西呢
那么gateway它实际上就会去验证你跟我所有的信息的合法性有效性
比如说像游戏服务器
有的时候会遭遇一些比如像ddos攻击对吧
那gateway这边的话其实要有一定拦截的功能
但是呢ddos更复杂的时候有更复杂的机制
我我的解压缩这些所有的操作其实都在gtav里面做完了
而gtav的话实际上工作任务是很重的
所以说很多时候无论是这个gateway的话
一般都会同时开很多个
随着你玩家的数量越来越多的话
越开越多
他们你可以理解什么呢
他们就是大厅接待员对吧
他来去接待你们这些所有人
真的就是服务的这个这个怎么就跟那个你们去那个啊
比如说某一个公司这些人是提供服务的
这些我们叫客服客服团队
他提供了所有的客服好
那么你有了这层link 3的话呢
哎接下来你就进入了游戏大厅
大厅很多时候呢它其实就是一个游戏
一个场景
其实你可以认为就是大厅实际上就是一个特殊的游戏模式
只是在这个游戏模式里面的话
你不能放技能了
你不能跟别人去那个打架
但其实有的大厅里面
比如说玩家可以在主持人里面彼此去决斗对吧
那可能这里面还要允许一定的这个就是玩家game play的功能
但是大厅呢很多时候会作为一个缓冲池
就是说让玩家在等待这些
比如说match making的时候
彼此之间能够被管理起来
就是其实有的时候大厅它不一定真的是一个场景
有的时候就是个虚拟的大厅也是有的对吧
是不是也有一个虚拟的大厅啊
大家在里面玩的也很开心对吧
before
我们真的进入到一一局的这个游戏里面来
那接下来的话呢就是大家不太熟悉的叫character server
其实在网游里面啊
就是用户的数据其实是非常多的
就是大家可能想象不到
就是说一个你你的一个角色
他的数据量肯定达到几兆甚至几十兆
因为大家想想看
我如果玩一个游戏
我在这个游戏里面
我发生的所有的事情
我获得的所有的道具
我以前完完成了哪些任务
这些数据大家一开始觉得不会多
但是随着我们的游戏时间增长的时候
这些数据会越来越大
而且这些这些数据的话呢
它会被各种各样的这个server都会去问
那这个时候的话呢
如果这些数据分散在比如说又是战斗的server里面去
又是交易的server里面去
又是聊天的server里面去
那是不是这个数据就会708落
谁也管不了了
对不对
所以呢一般在网游里面有一个专门的叫character server
它其实负担特别重
他就会管理所有的玩家的真正的这个属性数据
而且这个数据的话呢
它就相当于说你无论是发邮件也好
还是这个战斗中
比如说对方那个获得了某个道具交易成功了对吧
获得某个道也会战斗中
诶我我我这个突然受了一个很重的伤
那这个时候哦对这个有的时候不会马上同步与carry
但是的话比如说我要问一下
我现在是不是装备了什么什么什么一个道具
那这些东西的话呢其实都是character server要完成的这个这个任务
那么接下来就是大名鼎鼎的这个交易系统了
那交易系统的话呢
这个讲起来就很多了对吧
我们不展开
但是呢其实这里面大家记住有一个重要的属性是什么呢
就是交易系统它是有非常重的
我们叫做啊就是这个金融属性的什么意思
就是说你去写它的时候
要求保证它的安全性是足够高的
每一笔交易要保证它的绝对的原子性和安全性
全部都要可以roll back
这样的话就是说这样去保证就是在任何的情况下
打个比方
比如说啊对方的client交易到一半突然断断线了对吧
或者服务器突然发生了什么异常的情况
那么我们做的每一个transaction
它都能够被准确地记录下来
而不会出现我们担心的各种各样的异常的数据
所以说这个地方的话呢
就是当我们作为一个m游戏的时候
这一点是非常重要的
那接下来也就是大家经常熟悉的这个搜索系统
那基本就是聊天啦
邮件啦
其实其实在网游里面的话
这些系统还是非常的重要
而且它写起来其实并不简单
因为即使在一个小小的网游里面
我们还有一个叫什么拉黑别人的功能啊对吧
我还跟几个朋朋友一起组队啊对吧
开小群组聊天啊
分很多的频道啊
实际上依靠网游的这个搜索系统也是很复杂
甚至有的时候比如说邮件有专门的邮件server对吧
诶他这个就分得非常细
为什么呢
因为你如果把它全写到一起的时候
当很多很多人同时在彼此发邮件
彼此聊天的时候
你一个单一的server它可能就会炸掉
所以说呢哎这个social system也是要分成若干种不同的server
那么接下来还有这个match making
match making
其实对于很多网游来讲是蛮重要的
因为比如说我们做一个啊
大概比方我们作为一个lgleon这样的游戏对吧
英雄联盟这样的游戏
其实最重要的就是说把不同等级的玩家诶
你全部都要说我要匹配
他要把大家这个这个这个ranking值差不多的玩家
就是我们讲的这个大家的天梯分差不多的玩家
我们要把它集中到一起
这样的话你玩起来才会觉得这个好像相对公平对吧
那么其实match making的话
实际上在后面做了很多工作
比如说举个例子啊
就比如说啊
如果我们做一款射击游戏
假设这是一个全球联合匹配的这个联网的这样一个设计游戏的话
其实match max系统是非常复杂
为什么呢
它不仅要考虑大家之间的这个啊
就是说我们的这个rank值就是大家的那个scale
就是大家的技能是差不多的
我还要考虑你们彼此的延迟
我要尽可能把延迟相近
而且不要那么大的玩家匹配到一起
否则我才能保证大家之间的这个体验是ok的
所以说其实比如说大家在玩很多moba游戏的时候
很多moba游戏它的match making系统都是最核心的系统
就是要确保所有用户的匹配体验尽可能好
当然这里面有个有一个特殊情况
就是如果你远程的跟你的队友开黑的话
那他就没办法了对吧
那你们强行要在一起
那我只能配合你们了
对不对
但是呢一般来讲在匹配系统里面
如果你开黑的话
他一般会把开黑的玩家扔到一个单独的池子里面去匹配
因为你开黑了
我真让你匹配那些开黑的人
否则那些人不公平对吧
你看这里面就是设计一款网游的时候
他考虑的东西其实还是蛮多的
所以那接下来的话呢也是一个大家以前可能不会太注意到的
一个网络游戏的一个架构
就是数据的存储诶
这个东西其实啊就是大家想想看
如果我们要构建一个online gaming的世界的话
这个世界它是不是一直要存在的对吧
那我我的电脑
我的游戏可以关掉
对不对
但是服务器是不能关的
而且这里面的数据随时随地都会去产生啊
这这这里面产生大量的数据
谁来存它
谁来保管它
谁来负责去调用它
所以其实在这个就是online game里面的话
数据的存储设计是一个非常核心的设计
所以今天的这节课上的话呢
我们只能给大家点一下皮毛
比如说一般来讲我们会有三类的这个数据存储的这个服务
第一类的话呢就是这个关系数据库
比如像大名鼎鼎的micro对吧
如果你有钱
你可以用oracle对吧
但是好像我很少听到网游会用oracle的
那么anyway
就比如说我们举一个mysql这样的一个一个数据库
那我们游戏中很多的核心数据
我们都是用这种关系数据库存储的
但这里面其实讲起来就比较深了
就是说实际上在你一个网游的这个海量的数据面前的话
我们实际上采用的架构是类似于分布式数据库的架构
就是你同时写的时候
我会写到好多个并行的表里面去
这样确保就是说诶我写的效率图的效率足够高
而且万一有一个服务器这个挂掉了之后
我的数据不会丢掉或者不会毁坏对吧
还有什么冷热表呀
还有这种各种各样的
这个就是说我们的这个叫这个这个这个这个为在灾难备份啊
这些东西其实都是这个就是说做游戏的数据存储的时候
很核心要解决的问题
那么其实最早期的网游你们用的最多的都是关系数据库
但是呢随着游戏的发展
你会发现一个很有意思的事情
就是说你会产生很多呢没有
那么需要严格的就是a你用关系数据库的逻辑
就是诶我一句query的才能获得的数据
为什么呢
因为关系数据库它首先存储的负载还是比较重的
因为你一个数据存下去
他要把很多的建制建立一个他自己的关系表对吧哈希好
这样的话你用各种carry组合它才能查得到
但是很多时候比如说假设是我游戏里面最重要的log信息对吧
大家知道一个游戏里面一天能产生的log
可以以这个tb为单位产生它的log
但这里面的话呢我经常又要去对你们的数据进行query
但这个query的话呢又不需要特别的及时
但是呢我确实对这个数据要进行一定的检索
这个时候呢就是非关系数据库
它访问速度更快
更清亮的这种数据库又提上了用那个我们的这个那个需求
这个清单里面
所以比如像芒果db这种低轻量db诶
非关系数据库它又起了一个用处
所以说其实在游戏里面很多临时性的game state啊
或者说一些logging的信息呀
特别是game state
我们基本上就用非关系事故直接往里面去当铺
这样的话它形成一个非常大的一个数据集
但这个数据集的话呢
其实我们不需要那么高效率的
也不需要非常复杂的去查询
但这个数据对我们其实是有用的对吧
那现在再多讲一句
现在有的时候我们会用到
比如像数据仓库也能够去处理m所产生的海量数据
大家可能没有感觉
就是说如果我们真的做一个m的话
实际上他每时每刻都会产生海量的数据
大家打个补偿
比如说你玩一个网游
如果你发现你的道具丢了
你打电话给客服诶
客服小姐姐会说啊
你跟我说说你的角色id
你这个是因为什么事情丢了
那他可能过一段时间就真的能把你那个道具给你找回来对吧
那为什么呢
就是因为他要在这里巨量的这个数据里面
这个log里面这个尤其state的这个这个这个村这个cash里面
把你的这个状态找到验证
你说的事情都是真的
然后把这个道具还给你
实际上这对于一款网游来讲也是非常重要的
那么最后呢就是这是现代游戏中用的也越来越多了
我们叫做in memory storage
就是说叫内存数据库
这是一个现在比较啊还比较新的概念
其实也不算特别新吧
就是说我们发现随着游戏的系统变得越来越复杂
比如说一一款这个网游跑起来之后
我们可能有几百个server去从事探跑
那么这些是分布在我的内存中
那实际上呢我会产生很多的游戏的中间数据
这些数据的话呢
如果我只是road扔在哪
那么我们对它的查询和管理都会非常的复杂
这个时候其实我们需要有一个效率非常高
能够帮我们把这个数据管理起来
但是呢他又不会那么重的存写读写磁盘
因为读写磁盘就慢了嘛
对不对
那我们只需要在内存中把它保存下来的这个数据
说那个数据管理的工具
所以内存数据库的话呢
现在在就是游戏那个游戏的服务器端架构中也是越来越这个popular
那这件事情的话
我个人倒是蛮推崇这个内存数据库的
因为它实际上当你去你想想看我们有那么多的server对吧
这个然后这些server中间一些中间数据公共数据怎么存储
其实用一个内存数据库可能是一个更好的更整洁的一套处理方法
所以说的话呢这个其实就在我们的一个做一个online game的时候
你真的做一个m的时候
你会发现数据存储这一趴其实非常的复杂
所以说就像我们最早在讲做游戏引擎的时候
我会跟大家讲说
你要先从数据结构开始去思考
其实当我们去架构一个mm的这样的一个网络服务器的架构的时候
我会建议是从数据开始思考
因为你把数据想清楚了
你上面的各个系统的结构它也就清楚了对
所以说这其实就是一个m的一个大致的框架
那么这个框架呢基本上你是能做一个诶
有点那么意思的网络游戏了
但是呢这个好日子一般都不会长久
如果你的这个游戏引擎做的非常的好
上面做的游戏也很成功
你接下来会遇到一个什么问题呢
诶你就会有越来越多的玩家加入你们
当你面对了1万多个玩家的时候
你觉得还好
我一台服务器就能扛得住对吧
当我面对的是
就比如说10万个同时玩家同时在线
假设你很厉害
你做了一个百万玩家同时在线的时候
你会发现你的服务器根本不可能
无论你怎么优化
你都看不出百万很夸张了
比如说就10万玩家在线的时候
你的服务器可能就扛不住了对吧
那这个时候你该怎么去做你的架构去处理这件事情呢
那其实解决方法就是分布式的系统
也就是说把服务器的各个服务把它变成就是可以用多个进程
同时帮你满足的是一个分布式系统架构
而且分布式系统里面这些服务我可以加可以减对吧
那这样的一个架构如果做好的话
那恭喜你
你的这个服务器架构呢它就开始有弹性
所以说如果我们要讲大家要做mmo的话
就是massive multiplayer对吧
我们既然lan我们是massive multiplayer
那你就可能要考虑分布式的架构了
好那分布式的架构呢其实是技术原理上讲还是蛮简单的对吧
比如说我前面举的cart server对吧
我同时管理在rt里面就1万个玩家的属性的话
那我一个进程就可以了
但是现在我假设同时有10万玩家登录的时候
我管理10万玩家的数据的话
那我一个进程可能就一个cpu就吃爆了对吧
那我就可能必须要拆成十个服务好
这个时候呢你就要解决很多问题了
比如说同样一份数据不同的就是就分开来的这service访问他的时候
他彼此之间不会冲突
不会产生这种竞争啊
不会产生死锁
对不对
然后呢
当你网络发过来的消息的时候
有的时候因为这这么多服务
他可能说不稳定嘛对吧
那你这些消息冗余的发过来的时候
你能不能保证这个处理的叫密等性对吧
那密等性的意思是什么呢
就是说一个消息发了冗余了之后
你也不会出现异常
你能够自动地把那些荣誉的信息给过滤掉
执行你正常的逻辑
而且你的系统一旦分布式的时候
中间总有地方会挂掉
那你挂掉之后也不会影响你整个的逻辑
其实当你真的做一个mm的分布式系统的时候
那你的服务器各个服务
网络链接出现各种各样的问题
这就是你的日常
所以我们经常说什么什么某某大厂是土豆服务器
这里面要跟他们去这个小小的替他们解释一下
就是说如果真的要做一个鲁棒的服务器
这件事情其实是很多东西都要考虑的
否则的话你可以把业务逻辑做对
但是呢它的健壮性就是有问题的对吧
还有什么呢
就是说如果我把这个服务分得特别开的时候
如果有一个服务产生了一个bug之后
如果不去做好必要的防护的话
这个bug可能会在整个这个分布式的系统里面来回的震荡
震荡也就算了
还会什么呢
还会放大
这个就是本来是一个小型的bug
如果在在第一个服务里面没有被及时的给他
就是检测到
并且把它按掉的话
那这个错误的数据可能会传递到另外一个服务
另外一个服务面假设没处理好
他会把这个错误再放大
然后再传递出去对吧
r p c互相调来调去
有甚至有可能会出现什么情况呢
就会在这个系统里面无限的震荡
唉这个情况我讲的不是这个编出来的
其实在就是真的实战型的网络游戏团队里面
他们真的遇到这种bug
就是一个很难被检测到了
低频的一个bug
一旦他开始在系统里震荡的时候
首先你很难发现它
但是它会导致你服务器的性能急剧的下降
然后大家只能把那个rpc dump下来看
发现有一些rpc很诡异的被吊了无穷很多很多次对吧
这就是一个我们讲就是我自己蛮喜欢一本书
叫复杂系统嘛
就是说其实当我们构建一种分布式系统的时候
你实际上用的整个架构思维方式就是复杂系统的范围了
那在复杂系统里面确实有这种震荡的这种现象的存在对吧
那么你把服务分得这么开的话
你还要解决什么呢
还要解决他们彼此之间这个形成了各个业务的它的数据的一致性对吧
就是同样一个业务我们处理完之后
a的服务和b的服务产生的结果必须是一致的对吧
这样的话呢我们才能保证整个业务的这个绝对安全
所以这里也不一展开了
就是说当你把一个简单系统一旦变成分布式系统的时候
实际上就会对你代代码的安全性鲁棒性
而且他的这个这个要求就会高很多很多
但是它的好处也是显而易见的对吧
那么一旦我们有了这样一个分布式系统的话呢
哎我们就可以把load去balance去
就刚才那个例子
比如说我的character server对吧
我要同时管理1万个在线的这个玩家
我可以把它分成十个
这样每个人管1万个诶
我觉得能处理好了
对不对
那么这里面就有一个叫负载均衡的概念了
那为了解决这个负载
为了实现这个负载均衡
实际上有一个很重要的这个这个算法
这个大家可以就是关注叫什么呢
叫一致性哈
希他怎么去解决这个问题呢
我们先讲还是举刚才那个案例
就是假设我有1万玩家诶
我现在有一个有有一个有一局战斗正在如火如荼地进行
这个战斗里面的话呢
我这个玩家想这个这个获取了一个道具
这个道具的话呢再捡到了
捡到了之后呢
那我就要写到玩家的数据库
对不对
那我按照我们的说法说
这个玩家的数据应该存在哪
应该存在character server里面对吧
少在服务器端
现在跑的是这样的
好
我讲这个角色的i d叫101对吧
或者叫104
我们叫104吧
好好ok
我现在有十个这个character server s1 s2 s一直在s 10
那我到底这个是我自己是存在哪的呢
那我这个这个这个我这个game server我就一路的去问
说这个十个server s1
我是不是在你这s一说我不是好s2 问是不是我不是
我一路问下去
你想想看这个效率是不是非常的低对吧
那有没有一种方法能让我快速的知道我是在哪个server上
那大家说很简单嘛
我就分配嘛对吧
我就我就等等比的分配
但是这里面有一个假设的前提是我知道我现在有多少个character
但实际上的话大家如果对游戏有研究的话
你会发现character id啊
它是不重用的
它会一直去加的
但是真的在一个网游里面
玩家会不断的这个登录
就是增加新的character
对吧
诶但是有一个玩家logo的离开
有些character又会有些数字又是空的
所以说你多少到多少之间分配到哪一个character server
这件事情其实是不稳定的
另外一个的话呢就是说我们的这个server的数量
比如说一开始只有2万玩家在线的时候
我两个server就够了
对不对
这是三位玩家的时候
我就变变成三了
你如果一开始约定好说奇数位都属于server
一偶数位都属于sv没问题
但是我第三个server来的时候
哎你怎么办对吧
你可能这个事情就不对了
那我第四个第五个第六个呢对吧
而且中间假设我又发现这个就是用户量变少了
我又把一些server要释放出来
那我释放的时候
那我那些角色怎么办呢
所以这其实啊真的大家真的去写一个分布式系统的时候
你会发现其实类似的问题非常的多
这一类的问题怎么去解决呢
有一个很经典的算法叫一致性哈
希它的核心想法其实非常的简单
就是说无论对于服务器也好
对于play也好
我的设计对应的哈希算法
注意啊
服务器和那个player
就刚才那个例子里面
我设计两种不同的海峡
比如服务器我用你的这个ip地址端口号作为哈希值
我算一个值
但是呢我映射到比如说0~0到二的32次方减一
这个范围里面对吧
然后呢我把你的这个player id我也作为一个哈希值
我也算出一个也到零的30 30 33
然后呢我把我的服务器放到这个圆环
我们把这个东西把这个整个数据啊变成一个环
注意啊
只是环就是说零的下一个元素是什么呢
是二的32次方减一
我行那个花为什么是二的32次方减一呢
我假设用integer作为我的整个一个上限去管理它
我就是用一个int好
那你会发现啊
在这个环上面
这个服务器有一个分布对吧
我的所有的数据它其实也有个分布
那我定义一个非常简单的规则
比如说像逆时针规则对吧
也就是说我所有的cc的数据
我就逆时针方向找到我最近的那个server作为我的存储
其实这个怎么找的
因为server的数量不多嘛对吧
每个server的k值我知道
所以我很容易就知道说哦
比如说我知道s1 s2
我就知道我现在实际上是在哪个server上
我找那个server那个数据我就能找到server存储数据也遵照这个规则
那我假设有这样的一个哈希算法的话
是不是我就能够很方便的把这个数据分配到这个
就是整各个服务器上去了
而且的话呢但这个算法其实它有一个前提啊
这是我个人的理解
就是说你的这个哈希算法是要认公式
是要认真设计过的
因为那个阿强如果设计的不好的话
对吧
或者说player分布的过于集中的话
那你这个负载它其实也是不均衡的
这个里面的话其实是啊
后面还有别的方法可以优化的
但是这个其实是一个基础性的要求
那么好
这个时候如果我删掉了一个server对吧
我们先讲个简单的case
就是删掉一个server
那其实它非常的简单
就是说诶假设这里面我把s2 退出去了
那在s一和s3 之间的那些就是原来放在s2 上的那些server
它就顺眼的按照逆时针方向找到他下一个server
那找到的是谁呢
他找到了s3
那这样就意味着我把s2 以前的那些character全部扔到s3 就好了
他这个算法就是这么淳朴
同样的道理就是反之
如果我们增加了一个server的话
是不是就相当于在这个圆环中我又加一个这个这个中间的那个server节点
然后呢这样我就把这个珍珠的话在中间又分开了
其实你想想看
不就是一个珍珠中间无限分的一个问题嘛是吧
所以它非常的简单
那这个好处是什么呢
就是说它为什么叫一致性哈希呢
就是说只要你的player的这个哈希算法哈希函数和server的哈希函数
只要定下来之后
那我不需要进行任何的rpc的cory
我就能知道就是你的每一个player到底属于哪个server
这个事情就是他就把一个一个一个复杂问题变得非常简单了
因为大家知道就是在真实的一个服务器架构里面的话
如果我我让每一次都去问轮询一遍
所有的server说诶我在不在你下面的话
这个成本其实是非常非常高的
就是它的成本
一个是rpc本身的成本
大家想想看r p c怎么怎么发生的
对不对
我的这个这个指令对吧
先要去serialize
然后呢网络传输那边还有deserialize
然后呢出去之后
而且一般来讲一次cos是两次rpk
我先去问一圈
过一会儿等他另外一个rpc回来告诉我说哥们儿你到底是在还是不在
所以而且他你真的去问他的时候
那边的话大概率会做一个query
那做一个就是比如说至少是啊log n的一个复杂度去
才知道我在不在你上面
所以这个其实也是这个就是说一致性哈希的一个很好的地方
那么回到刚才我讲的这个哈希函数呢是很难设计的
特别好
可能会出现就是说诶如果server的数量不够多的时候
就算多了
所以这里面还有一个简单的算法叫做virtual server node的方法
就是说我会在这个环上
我会再随机哈希出来几个server
然后呢这些virtual server的话呢又会对这个珍珠进行一个更详细的划分
然后呢我这个vivirtual server
比如说我会映射回原始的server
实际上也能让这个负载相对均衡
这个就是一个很细节的算法
如果大家真的去用这种一致性哈希的方法去写这个分布式系统的话
大家可以去用一用对吧
但是这个我相信学104的同学
如果你刚刚入学写基础的时候啊
我不建议大家一上来写这么复杂的系统架构
因为这个架构的话
其实我刚才我一直在讲
就是分布式系统
其实是一个初步想想很简单的一个系统
但是你真的把一个很复杂的逻辑放进去的时候
你会发现他简直就是一个很简单的功能嘛
写一两个月是很正常的
因为就是写写其实很简单
但是你去真的上线测试
然后各种各样的边界情况处理掉的话
周期是非常非常的漫长的
ok所以我我自己跟大家分享一下
就是我自己的经验
就是说当我们的引擎写到这一块的时候
我们如果在线上出了一个bug
我每次都说
如果这个bug我能确定的重现它的时候
那这个bug我一定能把它解决掉
但是如果这个bug是什么
你服务器上线跑了三天之后
偶然的会有一次出现了这个非常恶劣的bug的时候
一般来讲写分布式系统的这个程序员就会非常的痛苦
因为他最恐惧的是说我都抓不住它
真的分布式系统
所以它的架构对这个大家的这个要求是非常非常高的
那么其实呢如果我们采用了分布式系统的话
还会产生另外一个问题
就是说哎呀有太多太多的服务了对吧
这么多的服务对吧
服务本身还要被管理
为什么呢
因为这些服务会不断的被创生
刚才我们讲了句
刚才那个例子就是负载均衡的例子里面
你玩家登录多了对吧
我要创建一些什么character server
game server
让你去处理我跟他的业务
但是呢诶玩家这时候到了半夜了
很多玩家走了
我这服务还得关掉
对不对
而且呢我起了这么多服务
几百个服务
上千个服务
有的服务可能一绕绕到一半
比如说自己产生了逻辑错误
他自己挂掉了
对不对
你这个别人都不知道
那接下来其他的服务就跟着一起
就是灾难性的雪崩式的
大家就一起崩溃了
对不对
那么其实在这里面
而且呢就是说这么多服务我怎么找到彼此对吧
其实大家如果观察一下
真的一个啊mo游戏里面的话
各个服务之间的连接啊
真的像一团乱麻一样
我以前特别喜欢用一个词儿叫spaghetti对吧
就是一种一种意大利面的特点
那种意大利面的特点是什么呢
就是说这个这个真的就搅在一起
你你想吃一根面条是不可能的
你一筷子下去
可能一碗面就直接起来了
那种对吧好
所以这个时候呢其实就产生了一个非常重要的一个需求
就这些服务怎么去管理
那这里面的话呢就是service management的
实际上就是叫最更专业的说法
叫服务发现
实际上也就应运而生了
这里面无论是阿帕奇的这个zoo keeper对吧
还是这个etc d e t c d这个名字其实特别有意思
好像e t c是个中国人写的吧
就是那个e t c的话
etc的意思就是好像linux下面的话就是分布式统有这么一个目录对吧
所以说呢就是啊这个就是有这个目录
所以e cd可能stands for distribute
所以说其实这些工具的话
他就帮你说把各种的服务就是你只要创建好的时候
诶
你通过一个简单的注册流程注册
因为我我们自己我喜欢用etcd的好
我们就注册到我们etcd里面去了
o好
你有有一段这个它的标识
它的地址
这样的话任何一个其他的服务想找你这个服务的时候
只要用这个标识
他就能找到你对吧
你可以这个时候呢你去query说这个服务有没有
他会说有
然后你跟他说诶这个服务以物有什么变化
你得告诉我啊
对不对
比如这个服务挂了对吧
这个服务或者有什么异常
你得告诉我
所以你要去卧室
它e d c d也说可以
没问题
我帮你看着他
只要这哥们儿有什么风水走动
我马上就告诉你对吧
另外一个的话呢
我起了这么多服务
假设有个服务已经挂了对吧
那我etcd演的发现说诶哪个服务内存已经爆了
他自己就死掉了
我把这个进场给杀了
诶
同时的话呢我会通知所有的观察者
那么如果需要重启这个服务的重启
其实这件事情的话就是这个service的recovery discovery或者是service的管理的话
实际上当我们在做一个大型分布式系统的时候
是非常非常重要的
那么对于一个mamoo的引擎来讲的话呢
这也是大家必须要做
我个人觉得就是在未来是大家必须要做的东西
否则的话这个服务器其实挺难嫁的
因为一一款网游的服务器跑起来真的是至少上百个服务吧
要起来
而且比如举个举个例子吧
比如说房间服务器对吧
大家那个冲进来打一个游戏
开个房间
打个游戏
那这个房间就会不停地创生对吧
要加和减
当然有的房间我可以reuse了
但是这里面的话它的管理实际上是挺复杂的
所以说的话呢服务管理实际上是一个非常重要的一个东西
所以讲到这一块的话呢
基本上我们的一个网游的服务器架构就是这么一个用用了这些工具
但是大家听完这一节啊
大家千万不要觉得我就能做过网游了
实际上真的去做一款这个mo的时候呢
这里面基本上每一页它都有很多小细节
大家可以在里面去去去思考
实际上大家现在听到这里的话
大家去做一个对战游戏
没问题不大了
但是你如果想做个m的话
还要补很多
其他的更多的技术细节和知识体系好
那接下来的话呢就是讲一个比较实战的两个问题了
第一个问题就是说带宽要去优化
这个大家会觉得哎我们学了半天做网游
为什么要学带宽优化呢
因为带宽优化真的非常重要
为什么呢
首先它会和你的这个游戏实战的这个成本息息相关
因为其实网络的带宽实际上对这个就是说游戏的影响特别大
特别大家想象一下
我做一个mm的话
特别是那种大场景
其实它的数据量是特别大的
就算说ok我不care对吧
我觉得我可以付得起这个网络的钱
但是这里面会产生另外一个问题是什么呢
就是说如果你的数据量不去做优化的
因为这是网络协议本身保证的
大家还记得我们前面讲了一些网络协议对吧
如果你的数据量过大的时候
它就会产生拥塞
拥塞的话
它就会产生latency对吧
而且呢就是雷特在过大的时候
有的时候甚至有的地方
比如说有些网关他会主动的帮你把这个网连接给你掐断
因为他要保证
比如说我们进了小区
小区配了一个策略对吧
你这一个人
你的网关需求量太大了
他就把你给掐了
因为什么呢
因为你这样用的话
其他人怎么办
其他就没得用了对吧
所以说其实对于带宽的优化
其实对于网游的体验来讲是一个非常关键的一个需求
那么怎么去计算这个带宽的
其实讲起来很复杂
实际上也比较简单
就是说第一个玩家的数量对吧
我玩家到底传输玩家数量有多少
第二个的话呢就是我大概多长时间跟用户做一次数据沟通
那其实对你的数据量是不是也是有影响的
诶那我也问题不大
但如果我每次都更新一大堆数据的话
那显然带宽消耗量已经比较大
所以其实我们在进行带宽优化的时候呢
我们实际上也就是对这三个点进行优化
那么好
那首先想到的是什么
a就是数据压缩
数据压缩这个事情的话
那就我这边当然大家知道就是有很多ononline的这种
就是说流逝流数据的压缩对吧
这个呢在有些网游你不会用
但有些网友你们不一定会用
因为还有可能考虑这会让get way的负载太大了
因为gateway本身还要处理很多很多的东西
其实在网游中啊
最常用的一种数据压缩方法是对这个浮点数转成定点数
也就是说比如说我们表达一个人的位置
大家想到什么是vector 3 x y z对吧
我的坐标对吧
三是什么
三个float
一个float是四个bite对吧
所以我还要花12个beat能表达一个人的位置
同样的其实vex 3的东西特别多
比如说我的速度
我的velocity对吧
又是个vector 3
对不对
又是x y z
whatever都可以
但是大家想想
那我去表达
比如说我的位置的时候
我需要用vector 3
首先在很多游戏里面
比如说我就是个大致基本的2d的一个品牌
或者说虽然我不是2d的
但是我人都是贴地的好吧
甲这种情况下
那我是不是只要传一个xy就可以了
我可以少一个channel
对不对
好第二件事情就是说如果我这个世界不是特别大
其实我用一个16位的定点数
是不是就能够把精确到比如说以厘米为单位的这个人的位置呢
其实很多时候其实是可以的
所以呢我们就会想方设法的把一些浮点量变成定变量
比如说我们要表达一个人的朝向
orientation quarantine的时候
有的时候我们就会用bt 4个beat表达一个人的朝向就可以了对吧
一个或者一个character的朝向
所以这种就是就是那个quantization
就是说我们把浮点数变成一个定点数的这种方法的话
而且这个实战中的效果是非常非常好的
那么所以呢有的时候为了配合这个方法
我们甚至会对游戏地图进行分区
就是我们每一个区的时候
我们不会把这个区弄得特别大
这样的话我用定点数存储一下你的位置也好
那实际上就可以表达得非常的准确
所以这件事情的话
大家千万不要小瞧
至少很多时候很容易的就会下降一半以上
那这个其实对网络游戏的这个体验稳定性帮助其实是非常大的
所以这也是我觉得在压缩带宽
我最想讲的就是
首先要用这种简单的方法进行数据压缩
那么第二种呢
其实哎稍微有点高深了
就是说我们整个世界上有那么多的对象
对不对
那我们是不是要把所有的对象都同步给我呢
大家会说不需要
为什么呢
因为其实只有一些我关注的对象对吧
比如说我要做开放世界的游戏
方圆这个什么这个几百平方公里
但是他们对我重要吗
不重要
对不对
很多时候我只关心我方圆1百米
2百米之内的这个情况对吧
那么那个所以的话如果是一个动作
这个这个这个这个近战游戏的话
我可能关注的范围会更小
所以说其实我们只要把相关的物体传递给我
这件事情我就可以去这个我做我本地的各种game play了
所以呢其实呢这里面就有很多的方法了
比如说我把这个世界分成一个个的这个静态的zoo对吧
把玩家呢放到这个zone里面去
那这个zone呢打个比方
比如说我们做个开放世界
我们每个市每个区域之间我是用pto连在一起
那put to隔开之后
那我在这个比如说城外发生的事情跟城内就没有关系了对吧
然后呢我进到一个比如说某一个巨大的building
building进去之后
诶
这样的话我在每一种情况下
我们彼此的这个信息全部都能隔绝掉
这种静态中的方法的话
就能非常有效地屏蔽掉大量的不必要的这个状态同步好
但是的话呢如果这个世界真的是开放的
我们不希望有photo
就不希望有这种传送门的这种情况发生的时候
诶有一个很重要的概念叫aa aa in interest就出来了
就是说我们以我自己为中心
就是以每个play为中心
我只需要关注我周围的数据的情况
唉这个就是大家如果真的有机会加入到一个网游团队的时候
你可能如果你在做这个game server的话
可能你一上来接触到的就是这个m a o i的概念
你在做任何消息的rpc同步啊
做任何的状态同步啊
结算的时候
你可能首先就要考虑说哎我只和我的a2 区
你们的物体有关系对吧
如果我的一个比如说什么技能啊
我的一个什么开枪动作啊
其实诶都要考虑a2 的这个范围好
那么这个l o l的话呢
其实讲起来非常简单
最简单的一种方法是什么
就是我给个半径对吧
在我这个半径之内的都是我care的
比如说我们是一个这个这个比如说是一个射击游戏
可能半径3百米
5百米就是我的范围
5百米之外
我不管了对吧
我的狙只能打5百米
实际上真实的世界狙可以打的很远
但是在游戏里面的话
因为那个空间是被扭曲过的
所以你一般打到5百米之外都已经觉得很远了
那其他的事情我就不管了
虽然你这个地图可以开放做的无比的大
那最简单的做法就是在整个世界里面进行一个query
那这个query的话啊
如果角色数量不多
没关系
你就暴力运算
但是如果角色数量多的时候
这其实就会有些问题对吧
那怎么办呢
哎其实大家想到了一个最简单的方法
那个我们的传统艺能就来了
在空间中画格子
是的这个大家千万别笑
在空间的画格子实际上是个非常鲁棒的好用的一个方法
比如说在早期的网游中
我们最常用的一个尺寸是多少呢
我印象特别深
就是1百米就1百米乘1百米是个格子
然后一个大家如果有幸看一些
就是古典时代的这个网游的这个这个代码的时候
你会发现就是服务器的架构
很多时候都会以1百米为1百米定义一个zone或者叫region对吧
然后的话呢这样的话我玩家在一个zone里面去站着的时候
诶
我方圆再去扩展两个
我大概这个这个方面你们的这些人我都会去看的到
所以说的话呢就是说我们每一个角色
我就把它扔到这样的一个nt里面去了
那这样的话呢就是我可以根据这个这个我自己的
比如说我们假设这个人感知的范围是3x3的zone
都是我的a o l唉对吧
就我当前假设在在这个zone里面
那么我3x3的周围的这个纵都是我关注的
那好那这个时候我这九个字关注了
那好那如果我就形成了一个我的a o l的这个一个列表
那当有entity进入和离开这个33怎么办呢
哎其实很简单
他给我发一个event就好了
就是说如果有一个人诶进入到这个这个zone的话
那我的event就会被更新
如果我离开的话
我的我的这个a2 就会被把那个删除掉
反之亦然
就是对于我自己来讲
我进入到一个zone
我我退出一个zone
我也会notify其他人
这一次因为玩每一个玩家进出众都是相对低频的事情
大家仔细想想啊
听上去好像很复杂对吧
大家仔细想想
大家都知道
其实呢这个频率并不高
因为1百米乘1百米
你在游戏里面自己跑跑
怎么着也得跑个几秒钟对吧
实际上很多时候它只要处理几十个这样的消息可能就可以了
并不会让大家想象的那么高频
这样大家的每个人的a2 都会相应的得到这样的一个更新好
那么这个时候呢其实就是我们就可以用这种简单的空间画格子的方法
我们就可以去query到我们的这个就是周围的这个a2 的这个区域
那这个方法呢实际上我们称之为叫一个空间换时间吧
就是说你实际上还要在空间形成一个点状的分布
有的时候大家会argue说这个格子到底是1百米乘1百米好呢
还是这个更大的好
因为有的时候你会发现就是格子画的太密
那你这个zone就太多了
格子画的太稀疏
那一个zone里面的character也太多了
你本身的效果也没有达到
所以另外一种方法呢
其实就是诶大名鼎鼎的数据结构里面的方法叫什么呢
十字链表法对吧
十字链表法其实呢呃说实话作为一个性情很有意思的
对不对
就是说诶我们以这个x轴为方向
假设我们假设空间我们认为是一个2d分布的
这个我们简化一下
那我沿着x轴把所有的a把所有的那个所有的object去这个排个序
然后呢我再沿着y轴把所有人排个序
那实际上我自己在这个x轴y轴哪个位置
我是不是都知道
然后呢我往两边都去找
那我就可以找到
就是比如说我说我的这个ai的半径
比如是150米
那我就在x轴上往前走150米
往后走150米对吧
那实际上我就能找到一个圈儿
一群这个一些一些的这个这个nt的id
然后呢我在y轴上做同样的事
我又能得到另外一圈的id
那么如果你在x轴的那个排序的列表上和y轴排序列表上都满足
都在我的这个这个这个满足的话
就是两个set有两个集合的交集的话
其实这些人是不是就是我的那个aoi
你们的这个案例挺大家想想十字链表是不是就非常的简单
它就能解决这个问题对吧
那么同样的就是当有任何一个物体在这个世界上去移动的时候呢
实际上呢我就会相应的去notify别人
我去更新每个人各自的这个ai这件事情也就能完成了
所以呢其实十字链表呢本身啊还是一个非常高效的一个一个算法
那么就是说当当然了
这里面大量的物体都在高速移动的时候
这个14连秒稍微有一个维护的需求
但其实我觉得你画格子的方法还是用十字链表的方法
都是大家各自的选择
我觉得这里面本身没有什么太大的这个啊
这个这个就是说一定说谁好谁坏
诶我们可以根据你现在所在的位置
我把这个世界我已经预先生好了
visibility的这个这个set
那这样的话在不在我的p vs里面的东西
我可以不关注
这个其实也是一个更宏观的帮助我们快速的filter out
我们不关注东西的这样一个点
那么这个对于这种就是说空间分割能力啊
分割感更强的这种游戏来讲会更也更实用一点
所以说其实啊就是a i是一个很宽泛的概念
但是呢在网络游戏做同步的时候
其实如果想降低带宽
是一定要做a i的
因为而且还有一点
它不仅是降低带宽
其实也节约了
这个是服务器端和客户端的算力
为什么大家想想看啊
你本身要处理要对逻辑状态进行更新
大家想想这个负载是不是很大对吧
而服务器端就更惨
把它传送出去
所以服务器端那边的传输的压力
其实你有时候你去理解一下网游的服务器端的话
很像什么呢
我自己的感觉像是一个快递公司
你知道吗
然后每一个这个一client像是每一个家庭住址
然后呢那个服务器端就很惨
然后呢pp的发给每个不同的地址
所以服务器端其实非常的辛苦
所以我们自己玩游戏的时候
我们觉得很简单对吧
我们在一起能跳能看
但实际上真的要大家去做引擎的底层去实现这个功能的时候
大家会发现它其实还是挺复杂的
很多的细节好
所以呢其实啊即使我们有了这个a i的这样一个东西啊
实际上在一真正的网游设计中的话呢
我们还有一个方法就是我们会降低这个server的这个传递数据的频率
其实这里我们会用到一个细节
就是说特别是对于那种啊
比如说近战型游戏或者什么游戏的时候
我们会把月在近处的jus
我们的这个object传自动频率会略高一点
比如你身边突然疾驰过的一辆车
跑过去的一个人
那稍微远一点
比如对方已经在50米开外
比如说三次两次对吧
比如说1百米开外
我每隔一秒
比如1百米到2百米开外
我每隔一秒同步一次
如果对方没有进行过多的急转弯
因为其实前面讲了那么多的差值和外差的算法
它基本能保证这个东西的平滑的运转
而且那么远的地方你不一定注意到
所以其实在真的这个网络游戏的这个架构里面的话
我们会做这样的一个策略
就是说根据它以我主体的远近
我们会调整这个信息同步的频率
这样的话才能够让这个带宽最大利用
最大效率的利用起来
所以呢这个就是对带宽的这个优化好
这段讲的稍微的有那么一丢丢的枯燥
但是同学们要这个不要在乎他枯燥
他真的很实战
如果你真的做做一款网游的话
这个能帮助你真正的节约你的这个运营成本好
接下来讲一个大家会比较感兴趣的问题了对吧
首先的话呢是高能警告
就是说这个反作弊对吧
还是这个这个这个这个这个非常高危的一个行业啊
就是说大家千万不要把nt去掉了
搞作弊了
作弊你就完蛋了对吧好
那为什么反作弊这件事情非常重要的
首先我们大家都在玩网游对吧
我想想谁在以前玩单机游戏的时候
我们有没有谁没有用过这种各种作弊神器呢
反正我承认我用过对吧
但是呢当我们去玩网游
网游的时候
一旦作弊的时候
对游戏也好
对玩家也好
都是巨大的伤害的
游戏就不用加了
对不对
对于玩家来讲
这个我们会有个调研会告诉你说这个这是一个stea的一个调研
他就说70%的玩家如果发现别人在作弊的时候
他就不想玩这个游戏了
确实是这样的
就是这很奇怪
就是我我自己玩单机游戏的时候
我可以作弊
修改我的血量
修改我的这个金钱
但是我玩网游的时候可以我作弊
但是我受不了别人作弊
所以作为任何一款online gaming的时候
反作弊是一个非常非常核心的一个系统
这是必然要面对和解决的问题
但是呢其实呢因为它变成了一个online game了
那么作弊就会变得特别特别的
这个怎么说呢
用一个词儿叫vulnerable
就是你会变得非常的脆弱
这个黑客会从各种角度来攻击你
比如说它可以直接修改你游戏的带那个那个主体
它把你的内存给你改掉对吧
甚至给你注入一段代码
你怎么办
这个就很麻烦
甚至把你的客户端给你破解掉
这个就很痛苦
那么他也可以不动你的客户端
他把那个系统的底层d k给你破解掉
比如说最著名的一个叫透明挂对吧
怎么怎么怎么做的
他可以这样
他把d3 d的就是这个rendering sdk的底层的那函数入口给你重载掉
所以当你一旦扩一些
比如说画一个画面片
画这些东西的时候
它被你全部变成线框了
所以在这个线框的世界里面
所有的东西就一目了然了
对不对
类似于这样的东西
就是说你根本防不胜防
那这样的话
比如说大名鼎鼎的某某精灵对吧
它就能解决这样的问题
你你你还真的是很难去提第二个
然后呢还有什么呢
就是说诶我不去动你的这个系统
我也不去注入到你的这个这个你的客户端
但是我干什么呢
劫持这个事情
甚至可以用第三就第三台机器把你的网络通讯给你劫持掉
这样的话我给你发一些假的消息对吧
那么这个时候其实你也会产生很多的作弊的方法
所以说其实啊作弊他真的是很难很难防的
那这边我就一次跟大家讲一下
就是作弊的各种各样的点
比如说第一种就是我去查内存
其实大家会发现就是说在作弊里面
我们很多说要抓这个用户的数据嘛
其实最简单的方法就是说我去定位内存中
哪个数据存的是你最敏感的数据
然后我把你这个数据给你改了对吧
因为特别是很多在客户端做校验的这种啊
游戏逻辑的话
实际上很多作弊器都是在你客户端找到你的数据
把你这个数据改了
所以这个方法呢对于单机游戏比较有用
比如说我们以前玩一些单机游戏的时候
我们会用这种方法去锁定我的血量
找到我的血量内存内存值
那怎么办
我就会一直改它对吧
那这样我就会在我服务器端产生很多的
那个就是如果啊这个我的数据就一直不变
但这里面怎么办呢
其实很多时候我们可以给客户端诶
我们给客户端加个壳儿
把客户端加密
然后呢到你这个游戏运行起来的时候
我实时的在内存中把这个客户端给给这个解掉这个壳
然后我这个ex可以运转了
这件事情呢它本身呢应该来讲是非常复杂的
是专门有公司给你的客户端加一个壳儿帮你保护
特别是你在做刚才我讲的
比如说我做个设计游戏
我这个设计游戏是用的client side detection的话
那事实上我的客户端的保护反防止被别人注入
是我最核心的一个需求
那么我相信就是很多游戏其实是做了这个房屋的
但是我跟大家讲一个很悲观的现实啊
至少以我所知道啊
几乎所有的客户端加壳的这个这个服务好像据我所知都被别人攻破了
我也不知道那帮人怎么那么强
但是如果因为你要是有真的客户端加壳的很好的软件的话
我肯定是第一个用的
但是实际上是非常的难
那么这里面呢还有一种方法叫什么呢
其实叫内存混淆
什么意思
就是说呃我可以把我最关键最敏感的数据
我不希望那个就是那个那个写外挂的人抓到的话
我可以对它内存进行混淆
刚才有同学问我说那个真同步的游戏怎么样防止别人作弊对吧
其实真同尊同步的游戏
防止别人的就是偷窥嘛对吧
你看到很多
你不要看到这个信息嘛
那其实有一种策略就是内存混淆
就是把我高度敏感的game play数据在内存中进行加密
只有在用的那一瞬间给它给它给它读读掉
然后再写进去的时候呢
我又把它再变掉
但是呢好像这个东西啊比较难破解
但是好像也有人能破
我也不知道
反正对吧
民间的高手实在太多了
所以的话呢简单来讲的话
就是你要想方设法的把你的这个程序保护起来
那也会把你的这个内存也保护起来
那么另外一种的话作弊的方法是什么呢
就是说诶我去修改你本地的文件资源
打个比方吧
比如说我做个设计游戏
我帮你把这个贴图资源全部改掉对吧
比如像这个吃鸡游戏
我把你本地贴图都改成发光的这个材质好了呀
那你里面看到的所有的敌人
所有的目标都非常的一目了然对吧
这个你你穿一身迷彩
你趴在地上对我来讲都是无视了
我就直接把你打掉了对吧
那就相当于直接开了地图透视挂
那这种问题怎么去解吧
解解第一个解决呢
其实啊一般来讲是用那个本地文件哈希值
就是说我要求你的客户端不停的去算以本地的资源文件的哈希值
然后把这个哈希值传上传到我的服务器
跟我的服务器的进行比较
如果我发现你这个哈希值不对
我认为你篡改了我本地的数据
那我就把你直接踢下线了
那这个其实是一个啊
基本上现代的online gaming的这个引擎啊都会做的一件事
因为确实篡改本地文件数据是这个非常常见的一种啊外挂的方式
这个确实是很麻烦
就是啊基本上所有的网游最开始遭到的攻击都是这
比如说刚才讲了
如果采取这种啊客户端的这个这个检测的话
那我就不听他说
我打众实时的消息过来
那服务器那边的话
它怎么检测
就算服务器检测
服务器可能不堪重负对吧
它会产生很多的问题
我们最核心的方法就是要首先是一定要加密
那这里面就讲到一个就是这个加密的一个细节了
就是大家知道在网络上这个连接啊
加密算法有两种
一种叫对称加密算法
一种叫非对称加密算法
那么精神加密算法其实比较简单
就是说诶我的客户端和服务器共享一个密钥对吧
然后呢我们之间的通讯就是用这个密钥来
但问题就在于你这个密钥存在哪呢对吧
如果你的客户端被破解了
别人很容易就知道你的你的密钥是什么
那好了
那你的这个客户端和服务器间的通讯
是不是就变成了这个透明大白于天下了
就是就相当于两个人打电话对吧
你说的所有的话
别人都能够谈旁听到
那么如果是这个黑客厅听到的话
那你基本上就没有任何的秘密而言了
对不对
所以这里面就有一个很著名的东西
叫做非非对称算法
什么意思呢
就是说呃你在这个就是客户端
我只给你一个公钥对吧
你破解了就破解了
但是呢我的服务器端是有一个私钥的
它两个对称是不对称的
那么这样的话呢就是你即使把我的客户端破解了
你知道我的公钥是什么
你也不会去知道我聊的内容是什么
因为你没有私钥
打不开这个数据
对吧嗯好
那这个时候呢我怎么去建立一个网游的这个网络游戏的链接呢
其实刚才大家讲的
我们讲这个在有一个login server对吧
在很多网游里面一般是这样
就是说我首先建立连接的时候
我会通过比如说像ssr这样的一个非常高度安全的网络链接
他走的就是一个非对称加密
但是非对称加密的问题是什么呢
它的这个速度比较慢
成本比较高
但没有关系
因为你登录的时候用一次对吧
当我们一个安全的网络链接建立好的时候
诶
我们用这个加密的方法把一个就对称的钥匙传下去
所以接下来我的客户端和服务器之间的通讯呢用的都是一次性的对称
下面的钥匙
因为你一旦破解了也没有关系
你只会破坏掉我一个客户端
你不会影响到我其他后面所有的链接
而且这个钥匙其实如果有必要的话
我还可以不停的去更换对吧
所以说其实呢在整个网游的这个服务器架构里面的话
我们的网络这个traffic是一定要加密的
其实很麻烦
所以其实在现代网游里面
很多时候我们都会对这个加密的问题是非常的重视
而且这个我也会建议就是作为一个引擎底层提供的一种服务
如果你做的是一款网络游戏的引擎的话好
那其实呢还有一种方法就是我们经常讲的就是这个啊软件注入
那么其实这个呢还是也是一个非常常见的这个游戏的作弊的方法
就是它通过一个钩子勾到你的游戏里面去
然后呢注入到你们的这个引擎代码
那这个方法怎么去怎么去处理呢
其实这里面我们要讲到一些很多仿作弊的软件呢
大家大名鼎鼎的v a c对吧
大家如果上steam的同学玩游戏的同学就知道诶
很多游戏好像进入了vc对吧
其实这些东西呢都是一些反作弊的这个软件
这些软件它的核心工作原理其实大同小异
其中就有个很重要的功能是什么呢
它会扫描你的这个内存中的这个游戏的签名
如果他发现你这个游戏被人家注入了一些奇怪的代码
或者内存的这个这个这个这个它的比如说它的check on
或者是说他的哈希值不对的时候
诶他就知道你被人家外挂挂上去了
或者是你被人修改掉了
那他就会直接认为你作弊了
但是他防作弊的方法有很多种啊
但是最重要的一点就是他会检查你的这个那个你的内存中的这个游戏
是不是没有被人改过
其实另外一个还有很重要的一个东西是什么呢
诶很多的可疑的外挂程序
比如说有些经常用的一些内存修改器啊
当你开了这样一些可疑的软件的时
候
像vc这些软件它就会检测到它就会报警
他说你这个账号是可能在作弊对吧
当然还有可能是一些常用的外挂
那常用的外挂的话
我们也会去检测
所以其实它这个东西就是道高一尺
魔高一丈
所以说实际上有人尝试去注入到你的游戏中间去
那像vac
像这个ez a c e a c的话
他就是专门去扫描这些可疑的进程
可疑的服务
所以其实只要大家做网游反作弊是一个最核心的一个需求
这你们讲个有意思的笑话
就是说呃我们在和某一个国家的这个开发者
我们在合作的时候
我们会发现一个很有意思的问题
就是说我们中国的游戏开发者会非常的关注做反作弊的问题
但是呢你会发现那个国家的开发者
他们好像就我不点名了
就是他们就是诶觉得好像为什么要写那么多反作弊的代码呢
会把你的这个游戏体验变得非常的差对吧
然后我们就很郁闷
就跟他解释说为什么这个很重要
但是呢在那个国家里面是这样的
如果你敢在游戏中作弊的话
在那个国家是一个违法行为
所以没有人会作弊
所以他们的游戏就不需要花很多时间去写反作弊的代码
那么这个就很有意思
所以我们也希望就是说如果有一天玩游戏的作弊就是违法行为的话
那这样的话那个也会让我们反作弊的压力会小很多
但是这个目前来看在全球想落地的可能性还是蛮小的
因为全世界确实有那么多的国家太多了对吧
每个国家的法律基础都是不不不太一样的好
那么其实呢这些以上讲的这些作弊啊
我觉得我们多多少少还是有些方法能够防范他了
反正就道高一尺魔高一丈嘛
我们就反正就反复的去追嘛
但是有一种作弊说实话真的是非常难的
就是ai的作弊对吧
现在的人工智能实际上是非常的强了
对不对
假设我用人工智能的技术
我直接图像识别出来敌人在哪里对吧
然后我我去移动
我就training我的鼠模拟鼠标和键盘的操作
然后我就开始去这个这个训练这个机器人了
比如说那我真的我什么作弊方法都没有用了
对不对
因为对方是真的是很真实的操作
当然这里面我可以检测说你虚拟的键鼠标键盘操作
我可以检测你
但这个其实已经很难了
那么实话实说呢
当我看了这些ai作弊的这些这些这些视频的时候
我不知道诸位看了什么感觉啊
反正我看了觉得挺爽的
你不觉得你看这个打的比我们的这个人打的要牛逼多了吗
真的是行云流水啊
这个见面爆头
见面爆头看起来一种莫名其妙的爽感
所以有时候我怀疑说我要以后要不这个游戏就直接交给ai去打了
我们就在旁边一边吃着泡面
一边看着他枪枪爆头
然后两边的ai的话相爱相杀
他们彼此之间互相k讲
我的ai干掉了你的ai
我觉得也是一种游戏玩法
但是说实话这个其实是真的是很难很难防的一种这个作弊的形式
而且这件事情呢说实话现在的门槛已经是越来越低了对吧
现在越来越多的比较像优菈的
已经出了v5 v7
那你在一个图片中自动的识别别人
甚至你可以精准到知通过skeleton识别出来哪些是关节
哪些是重要的头部对吧
我可以做到枪枪爆头这件事情其实已经门槛越来越低了
所以说其实呢在下一代的反作弊的这个软件研发里面的话
其实ai作弊实际上是一个啊
我觉得大家重点考虑的一件事情
确实是特别是对于这种对抗性越来越强的游戏的话
那么我们这也是我们这个行业所要面临的一个问题
说实话到目前为止
我也没有想到这个有什么好的方法
当然了
这里面也有一些方法
比如说用魔法打法魔法
用ai来识别ai作弊对吧
也有人提出这样的方法
但是我个人觉得这种方法还在一个非常早期的阶段对好
那所以说的话呢其实这里面也有一些很很淳朴的做法
我们发现了一些可疑的行为
通过大数据统计发现你这个人这个行为有点可疑
跟你传统的这个比如说爆头率啊
你的这个击杀力数据明显出现不对了
玩家给你打分
说你到底是这个作弊了还是没作弊了
但这件事情呢我个人一直觉得可能有一点点难
因为你并不知道这个降下者是不是相对公平
而且呢呃我反正听说了很多的事例
就是有些高玩玩家
他一通行云流水的操作发挥到非常的了不起
就被其他玩家误判为作弊了
然后就被干掉了
这个说实话当然你是威慑爸爸无所谓对吧
你就干了就干了呗
但是对于一般的一个游戏或者游戏引擎来讲的话
如果这么做的话
还是有点狠了
所以说我觉得靠人力去判断是一个方法
但可能也未必是一个好的方法
但是呢诶这个还是我们今天这节课中
唯一一个跟技术没有关的一个方法去反作弊好
那么其实呢就是基于统计数据的方法
就是就是我刚才讲的
其实正常玩家的模型是有一个pattern的
对不对
我把那些开了挂的用户的信用模型其实可以训练成另外一个pattern
这样的话呢它可能不会纠结于单次的操作
单次怎么样
但是它确实能够从浩如烟海的战局数据中
我能detection你在作弊
这个确实是这样
但是呢这个假设就是那个写ai作弊器的人比较笨
如果我ai写的真的足够聪明
我就比你正常的操作好那么一丢丢
比如说我这个ai只是给你提供一个叫辅助瞄准的功能对吧
大部分操作还是人在做诶
我只是这时候想作弊的时候
我开一下辅助瞄准一下
让我发挥稍微那么启动
那么一下那这个你能发现我吗
我觉得他的那个就是那个这个这个这个这个deep
就是那个就是数据的这个deep learning的这个算法要求还是比较高的
但是呢这个东西这种东西呢我认为就是道高一尺魔高一丈吧
也是作为这个未来技术发展的一个方向
所以呢其实这个啊还有一点就是说
其实啊所有的其实我个人认为一个比较实用的一个反作弊的方法
是这样
就是说一般来讲做外挂程序都是牟利的
所以呢它就必然会在网上去叫卖
对不对好
那你可以把已知的别人做的外挂的气
把它的这个特征给识别出来对吧
总是有signature的
那么我就在这个内存中扫描
我只要扫描到已知的外挂的东西
我就可以知道你的作弊了嘛对吧
所以说呢其实这个方法其实对于所有的商业性的外挂
是一个非常好的方法
所以综上所述啊
就是如果你想做一个大家真的不会弃坑的一个online game的话
那反外挂实际上是一个叫长期战持久战对吧
当然了
你每天要忍受你的用户更对你各种指责
但是你自己是知道这件事情其实非常的难
所以这也是就是下一代online gaming的话
我觉得必然要面对的问题
当然有同学会说诶我是不是用了这个cloud gaming
这个反作弊就不用解决了
唉in siri确实是这样
但是啊大家记住我前面讲过了
如果对方用ai作弊的话对吧
你怎么办
人家模拟的是鼠标键盘的操作对吧
人家读取的数据就是你的屏幕信息
我觉得一样
你还是防不了的
所以说啊这个事情还真的是非常有意思
很要挑战
ok好的
那最后呢我们讲到这一块的话
我们的这个online game的这个架构啊
基本上就讲完了
最后呢我们就荡开一笔
就是这也是课程结束的时候
我们就放飞一下自我
那个如果我们要构建一个真正的开放世界对吧
那怎么去构建呢
那首先你要做第一件事情
就是你得把这个世界做得足够大吧
足够大
里面能放入足够多的这个character
对不对
那这个时候如何构建一个scalable的实数据呢
这个其实很复杂
那我们今天就讲一个最简单的一些它的这个知识
就是诶我怎么去把这个世界
这个就是把这个世界做的能够hosting这么多的人
这么大的地方
其实啊它的方法其实也非常的简单
我们去看整个世界的这个这个构建啊
无非也就三种模型
第一种呢是中间的叫instancing
就是说诶我们把世界分成副本对吧
大家往往有都知道下副本对不对
其实一个魔术里面我可能有几万人
是更多的人在一个服务器里面
但是的话呢同时下副本就那么十几个人
所以我这个世界里面就是每一个副本里面就有十几个人
就是比较简单的
那么还有一种做法是什么呢
诶我真的要实现于开放世界
我把世界分块
就是刚才我讲的分成一个个zone对吧
那么好
那我们把这个世界分成无数次zm之后呢
诶我这个人就可以在zm之间一来一去对吧
那么我怎么把这个room做的
让你感受不到它有边界的存在呢
唉这里面肯定是有方法的
或者说呢我这个世界呢room
你可以理解成是对这个世界的横向的这个空间上的分割对吧
但实际上还有一个方法是什么呢
我们叫做replication
就是说诶我们这个世界分很多的这个虚拟的层
我们把成千上万的玩家分到不同的层上去
这个跟我们前面讲的那个分布系统里面那个就是load balance是不是很像
就是说我每一个就是这个这个这个这个这个这个世界的层的话
我的hosting
比如1万个玩家
假设现在10万玩家在世界上跑
我就分十层嘛对吧
那我这个数据其实也能够处理
所以其实如果大家想构建一个开放世界的话呢
诶你最重要的就是让你的这个game server具有这种stability
那么好具体讲一讲这个怎么去做一个这样的是第一个几种方法呢
就是用zi的方法
我怎么去构建一个无缝的zone呢
其实很简单
我对这个世界还是分块对吧
那每一个角色
你每一个character你属于哪个zone的话
那我就放在那儿呗
那我一个用上的人
我假设是不会太多
这里面其实有个细节
就是说啊实际上的话character就是觉玩家在这个世界上的分布
比如说我作为一个很大的开放世界
比如说啊几千平方公里
但是已经很大了
对不对
那我假设有几10万个玩家撒上去的话
它的分布式会怎么样呢
是不是有问题对吧
很多zone里面可能没有人
很多zone里面比如像主城都已经塞爆了
但是你可能就要炸掉了对吧
那这个送的话
其实它是可以动态的这个这个创建或者添加的哦
就是划分的
就是一般来讲我们会用那个四叉树在进行不断的划分
但是呢划分到一定小的事情
我们就不划分了
这个里面的细节我们以后再呃
后面会简单讲一讲
但其实这个有很多小细节处理好
那有这样的一些room之后呢
接下来我们就做一件事
其实你唯一要处理的问题就是这个角色要跨边界了
从a送到b中的这个问题对吧
那怎么办呢
其实首先我们不讲了一个a o i的概念吗
每一个角色关注的什么呢
不就是我旁边一个半径的区区域吗
那我有了这样一个半径
我在zone之间呢做一个就是border边界好
那么当每一个角色到了这个边界的时候
我就知道说你进了这个边界
虽然你还你现在还在a中za
但是呢你虽然没到zb
但zb的玩家应该要能看到你了对吧
因为否则的话你会当你从a中到b中的时候
会突然看见你出现了这个感觉
是不是很奇怪对吧
哎这个时候其实做法其实非常的简单
就是说我在za的那个服务器上
zb的服务器上
我只要你的这个character这个entity
你在zone的那个区啊
border那个区域里面
我会去做你的一个ghost诶
这里面就引入了ghost的概念了
就是说啊
虽然这个其实就是说你虽然这个时候
你这个比如说我们举一个nt da为例
你这个虽然还在a这个这个nt里面去
还在a这个zone里面
但是的话呢在zombie里面我会做你一个ghost
这样做zombie的玩家是能看到你的
只是你真正的逻辑
你真正的行为其实还是有原来那个a的那个server去hosting了
对不对
这件事情其实就完美的解决了
而且因为你我们只处理它在波段里面的情况
所以说是用我们就假设ghost不会太多吧
我们第一个有了这样一个ghost
那么第二件事情是什么呢
诶当我们去跨越这个zone的时候
实际上他就做一个简单的fleeping
就是比如说这个nt体跨越从za到zb的时候
他越过那个边界线的一瞬间
我本来是在za服务器里面的这个实体
b服务性的ghost
然后呢我把数据迁移一下
把a里面变成ghost就可以了
但是呢实际上在实际做的时候呢
我们一般会做一个小小的一个缓冲区
什么意思呢
就是有的玩家特别的坏
他就专门当然玩家其实也不知道你的动画在哪对吧
假设有个玩家特别的坏
他就反复的在你那个边界那边来回来回来回抖动
那你就会就会不停的这两篇的数据考来考去
这种情况还真的是有的
所以真的我们要再做一个就是无缝的这个大世界的时候呢
我们一般会做一个阈值
就是说诶你得穿过了这个zona的这个边界
比如说过了20米
30米了
诶
我在考虑万一迁过去对吧
那么你如果从那个b又后悔了
往往回跑
你跑到一段距离之后
我才切回来
这样避免这种高频的震荡对吧
假设有一个老哥不长心
他就老是沿着那个边界线跑的话
那你这个两边服务器忙得要死
数据考来考去考虑考虑去对吧
所以的话呢其实这里面还会有一些相应的处理
但它最核心的思想就是里面大家记住一个核心的思想
什么就是ghost
我要做个ghost
就把这个哎这样我两边就感觉好像彼此真的存在了
但实际上我们并不在一个服务器里面
所以这就是一个无缝的大世界
用用的方法来解决
那么另外一种方法就是replication
其实刚才如果大家理解的什么叫ghost的概念的话
其实replication就好理解了
就是说我这些每一个character呢
我是扔到多个这个世界的镜像里面去处理的
这个世界足够大
但是呢我比如说你可以想象一下
我们把这个宇宙这个把这个这个这个这个一个城市分了很多诗意的层
对吧
每一个cd的每个每一个玩家都扔到了不同的层来处理
每个层上平均那处理1万个市民
那我但是呢其他的这个九层的市民
他在我那个层上面的这个是个ghost
但是呢这个ghost其实是虚拟的
有的时候我只是在穿做的ri的时候
我会去取一下它的数据
所以用这种简单的rap思想的话
那我也能够去处理很多很多的用户
但是呢如果我们去真实的去构建一个哎这样的一个大世界的时候呢
那至少我个人会推荐
就是说应该把两个方法去结合
你既要用空间划分的这个思想
而且这个划分的思想最好是要用这个adaptive的
这个这个这个这个这个这个划分
为什么呢
因为就像我刚才讲的
就是说真的你做一个上千平方公里的地方的话
大家想想玩家都喜欢在哪聚集
玩家都喜欢在主城里面聚集对吧
野外很多地方大家都是空着的
所以你这个zone到底花多大都是不合适的
所以呢它一定是就是当用户聚集的时候
它会这个划分会再变得更密的
但是注意这个不能够划分的就是过于的迷
为什么
因为你老是动态的去切割他的话
这个数据会在各个服务器之间来回跑来跑去好
但是呢你这个z又不能变得太小
因为z变得太小之后呢
你的a i又不能太小对吧
a i一般都是要12百米左右
那你z太小
如果比如说zone太小了之后
你这个数据就是老是会来回的这种搬来搬去
所以呢到了一定的尺寸之后
假设我在这个方圆100x100的平方米的地方
角色数量已经超过了我单台服务器的hosting能力怎么办
哎我在下面再去点他的replication来去分担他的压力
所以呢我就说这两个东西的结合
是一个相对完整的这样的一个解决方案
所以同学们如果想做一个开放大世界游戏
你们可以尝试用这个结构对吧
所以的话我觉得就是说我们经常讲
就是也许这就是我们的online gaming的未来对吧
就是像绿洲这样的一个世界对吧
我已经看到地平线上已经有很多的这样的产品在研发
确实是这真的是啊
也会让我们非常激动的这样的一种游戏的类型
所以讲到这一part的话呢
也是我非常开心
就是用这这这一页图纸作为我们这个online gaming section architecture的一个结束
心中想的一定是个绿洲这样的世界
ok好的
今天这个课程的话两个半小时好
接下来的话呢就是也感谢一下我们的课程组的小伙伴们
大家那个非常的辛苦对吧
每节课都是这句话
这个台词再用一遍也不嫌也不嫌麻烦
然后呢接下来就是我们的reference方
这一节课的话reference也是比较多的
确实是我自己的感受
就是我们这两节课的话
基本上每一节课的内容如果真的在学校里去讲的话
可以讲一整个学期吧
就内容量挺大
所以呢确实很遗憾
就是在课程上没有办法给同学们讲的很细
很多算法其实有很多的细节才能真的做出来
所以呢我们也尽可能的把这个各个算法的这个reference交给他
比如像这一页的话是就是replicate character movement的这一部分
有这样的一些比较好的一些论文或者是一些文献
大家可以去读
然后呢比如说像那个like medication
其实就是我刚讲的like composition呢
还有heatregistration的
基本上在这些文章
你们会有那么这个m网络网络游戏的架构呢
其实资料不是特别多
但是大家可以看一下
有这些东西
其实今天分享的很多东西都是我们自己的经验之谈给大家
那这个架构呢其实也是就是被行业里面官方验证的这样的一个架构
但是这里面其实还有很多很多的细节
那么接下来呢还有就是说这个带宽怎么去优化
也有一些gdc的文章跟大家去分享对吧
然后还有就是反作弊
反作弊的文章就比较多了对吧
大家有兴趣的话
可以在你们深入的研究
但是还是那句话
大家一定要学好的
不要学坏的
一定要学antchat
千万不要去学chat
ok然后所以呢这就是我们今天内容的全部好了
同学们有什么问题
那个我们可以在这里面去交流啊
第一个问题是有同学问我说
如果玩家在服务器端做了微调
这个命中判定这个服务器能不能判定出来啊
这个答案应该是取决于你是什么什么怎么做的
假设是客户端判断的话
那按照刚才我讲的守望的一个案例的话
他打中那么大的一个盒子都算你打中的话
那确实是判定不出来的
所以他的假设是客户端是不会被compromise
是不会被人hack进去的
那如果是这个就是说采取的hate registration
在服务器端判定的话
呃就是说如果你发射的那个射线是真的命中了那个目标
而且服务器端做做那个就是luck composition
他算的结果也是一样的话
那他就只能认为你就是真的击中了对吧
假设你在本地其实没有击中
或者你调整了
你在本地强行的把你的这个就是那个对方的位置做了一些移动
就是跟你差值算法不一致的话
那服务器那边肯定是认为这个事情是不对的
他会让你判定不出来
所以说啊就是看你微调的性质到底是怎么回事
就是其实很难讲
因为其实客户端微调你可以微调你枪的角度
你可以微调你的这个这个你的靶子的位置
一般来讲的话
如果是hate registration
你动的是靶子的位置的话
那么我的那个服务器端的算法的话
会跟我服器上算的不一致
那我可以判断出来
但是如果你微调你枪口的位置
你真的是通过某种那个外挂把你的枪真的对准那个人去打的话
那我服务器端真的是判断不出来的
啊这个问题是同学问我们说分布式系统在游戏行业应用广泛嘛
呃其实在早期的时候呢
就是网络游戏的服务器架构没有那么复杂
其实我知道最早的有些很厉害的游戏啊
它整个服务在一台服务器上
就是一台物理机上就跑完了
真的很厉害
而且那个游戏产品非常的厉害
真的是常青树
但是呢随着现代网游的这个复杂度越来越高
现在越来越多的这个服务器的引擎的
就是服务器的架构的话
采取了分布式系统架构
但是整个行业其实我的理解啊还是在一个过渡阶段
就是说大家越来越多的用这个分布系统的架构去架构
整个服务器引擎的底层
就保证这个就是我们的整个服务的现状性
所以我觉得这件事情在未来的五到10年就要不了那么久
可能3~5年吧
我觉得就会逐渐的成熟
而且应该我也会成为这个行业的一个标配哇
这个第三个问题太难了
同学问我说无缝大世界的mmo实现的难点有哪些
首先第一个这个吴桐大师的m我自己还没做出来
所以我不敢说我知道什么难点
因为这件事情其实是蛮挑战的
那么我觉得他第一步的话不能说难点就在我们的课程
最后一把讲的就是你首先要做一个足够大的世界对吧
能让诚信上的玩家在世界里面走来走去
那么这里面的话呢其实除了你的server host能力
还有一个很复杂的东西是什么呢
就是说哎这些玩家不是只看到彼此的
对不对
他们还有很多的这个消息
我有很多的行为
比如说我可以开枪打到那个远处的敌人呢
我可以突然把一个墙摧毁掉呀对吧
而且这些人的话会有很多其他的这种transaction这些行为啊
这个时候就像我们讲的这个复杂度的话
又变成了一个m平方的复杂度
所以这个时候实际上当这个世界如果只是静态的
大家只是在里面走来走去
say hi
跳个舞对吧
做一些简单的战斗
操作比较简单
可以在世界里面去构建战斗
创造所有的事情的话
那这个它的复杂度其实还是非常非常大的
因为今天我们看很多网游的架构啊
实际上它还是分房间的价格
就是说当用户进入到战斗模式的时候
它很多时候还是会进入到一个个房间
就真的在这个世界上
你能让就是几万甚至几10万的人在一起
又是战斗
又是移动
又是交易
又是对话
又是做各种行为的话
其实啊他对其他各个server就是不仅仅是这个就是这个世界的hosting server
比如说甚至连聊天
连这个就是啊
我觉得就是基本上所有的server都得要重新按照分布式的架构
而负载均衡的架构重新加一遍
而且要保证它们叠在一起还能work
所以这件事的话呢啊其实是非常非常挑战的
这也是为什么举个例子吧
比如说啊大家知道就是像那个最早是epic的tim sweeney
他在游戏引擎界就讲说matters对吧
就是元宇宙
但是呢其实就是team的话
他自己在他的一个talk中也就讲了
就是说构建manners的这个底层的这个引擎
它其实有很多的要求的
这个这个要求的话
实际上他讲的比如像persistency啊
这个这个整个世界的事物原子性啊
这个要求的要求非常的高
那么到目前为止的话
我至少在商业引擎里面
我看到大家都在往这个方向去努力
但是还没有人敢说我交付了这样的一个这个技术平台
这也是我认为下一代游戏引擎很值得大家去努力和推动的东西
所以这里面的话呢很值得我背去跳进去弄
如果同学们有兴趣去做的话
我非常愿意跟大家去探讨
因为确实只作为我个人来讲的话
就是我的终身的职业梦想
真的就是作为一个游戏人的话
作为一个游戏引擎的这个这个程序员
这真的是没有什么比比
这个让我更兴奋的事情
而且我自己非常清楚说这件事情很难很难
就是可能需要我们再去努力
五到10年才能交付这样一个世界出来
ok好的
那今天要不就先这样
好的
那就下一节
同学们下一节课的话
我们就休息一周
充满乐趣
充满挑战的这个我们的游戏引擎课
那同学们
我们下下周见